two of my bosses have told me I don't
like Jocko interesting without giving
any value valid reasons their ego is in
the way how do I flank them to help them
see the path my belief is that they're
afraid of the truth and they say they're
afraid of the truth they see in extreme
ownership okay so yeah I mean clearly
ego could be a problem here as a leader
you know who wants to constantly be
compared to some other leader right you
know if you were teaching to jiu-jitsu
well the way that do the way that Dean
teaches this you know that that would
make you mad afterwards so that could be
part of the problem that's death that's
definitely that's way up there on the
list of possible things could be the
military flavor right some people don't
like the military flavor thing so that's
that's okay it's it's can turn some
people off that I want to hear about it
that's fine the reality is here's the a
but here's the reality of the situation
okay what is there to not like about the
things that I talked about right so
let's say you know what I don't like
people taking ownership I want everyone
to make excuses and blame each other
right it doesn't even make sense you
know instead of yeah we I don't want to
hear about this cover move I want
everyone to ignore each other and worry
about themselves right like that makes
no sense whatsoever
you know if key keeping things simple I
don't wanna hey look I don't want to
keep things simple I want everything to
be so complicated but no one knows
what's going on right like these things
they make no there's no human being no
one in a leadership position that would
want everyone or that would that would
go against what these simple principles
so how do you fix it then right what's
the problem one here's a couple and
actually this was a Twitter thing and a
bunch of people gave great responses on
Twitter after I kind of highlighted it
one one of them and my actual responses
like hey just don't you know stop using
my name you know stop saying well Drock
elicit because you
imagine how annoying that was with
chocolates in you know when you're in a
leadership position it's like that's
gonna really great on somebody so so so
throw that out the window don't pit it
as me Jaakko against what your bosses
are saying no don't do that you've set
up an adversarial relationship with them
and you've set up for a never ever see
relationship with me and I've ever you
met these people before know who they
are even know what business they're in
but what you've done by constantly
harping on it is you've pissed them off
and now they're saying dude quit talking
about jakka we don't care cuz also the
way that he's in turn just the way he's
being offensive in approaching these
things means that he has a little more
listening and growing to do because if
you really want to approach your boss or
you know he asked about Frank and his
boss well the way you flank someone
isn't going hey the way jocular says you
should do this no that's not good so let
the principles work on another another
person pointed out you know
hey don't hey stop trying to impose your
things on them like take extreme
ownership how's that sound you step up
and start leading you do your thing you
perform well quit talking quit trying to
force these things down people's throats
and give them space give them room and
then they'll recognize that you're doing
a good job if you label it with
something that you know they don't like
well then they're gonna not gonna like
it no matter what you do no matter what
you do that's gonna be problematic
don't bludgeon them with with will you
know I this blah blah blah no don't do
that
hmm take let put your ego in check how's
that sound for your you go and check a
little bit make the ideas that you're
talking about their ideas get them to
talk about ownership you know get them
maybe they call it something else other
than extreme ownership
maybe they call it you know personal
accountability okay awesome that's great
yeah I really like that I really like
what you've come up with boss I mean
with oh well now they're in the game and
they don't realize that you're talking
about the same thing
that's fine don't they don't ever have
to realize that they don't ever have to
realize that so maybe there's some
people or some people that don't like
even do the team's just people that like
they didn't
me didn't matter didn't matter where
what the the principle was didn't make
no that's no it's like no like hey just
just just don't don't attach my name to
it yeah and go and do be a good leader
how's that so those are some things I
think if you live live the principles
act on the principles no one's gonna be
mad at you for taking ownership and
responsibility of what you're doing
unless you say oh you like how I took
ownership of that well then you might
paint yourself into a corner with yeah
stupid where they end up not accepting
what you're doing yeah and they'll get
mad at you for stepping on their toes of
course and it is also as you do this as
you take ownership don't rub their noses
in it mmm you give them credit how hard
is that
you know you come up with a pro solution
the problem say hey you know actually I
got this idea from something I saw you
do it really right that's how you that's
how you flank them and took ownership
for this problem
oh really oh here we go extreme I don't
say that you know it's like a boss I I
wanted to make sure this got done
correctly I was watching the way you did
bah bah bah bah
and you go from there give them the idea
you make sense it yes I wonder how the
boss got introduced to the concept of
Jocko for him to eventually hey not like
in this situation it probably was like
you know multiple repetitions of what
and didn't pick up the vibe yeah which
is like hey I'm dealing with someone
with a big ego and they're not gonna
take well to me talking about this other
guy's leadership style do you you don't
want to be compared to some other leader
if you're in a leadership position yeah
and I know man also it's kind of the
same thing but a little bit different
the that thinking about that type of
scenario man that's the worst that's
like as a boss I would think that that'd
be really bad because okay so here
here's a situation so I make videos
sometimes right and so let's say I'm and
actually this is an actual thing that
actually happened where okay so I made
this video for this will say client
and classic okay you know they look at
it and it's typical you know they'll
have some input maybe some information
they want to add or take or change or
whatever and then um this guy said oh
yeah I'm not sure about this part I
showed it to my wife and she said you
know X Y Z next I'm thinking okay I get
it like okay you showed it to people
that I understand but I was like wait
wait so this is a video made for you in
your deal you know kind of thing and you
went and showed your wife and then now
she has some kind of input she's not
part of this deal you know now you're
like citing your wife's critique and
like all this stuff and it doesn't make
sense by the way as far as what we've
discussed and all the stuff right so
look so the wife is good now I kind of
have this kind of disdain for the wife I
don't know wife at all by the way so I'm
like I'm just not feeling the wife in it
where ego got in the way and it's
natural is what I'm saying where it's
kind of like I thought we were doing
this video kind of together and I'll do
this for you and you gave me the input
right now you involved your wife in it
who through the whole thing off but
she's not even part of this little thing
right now really hard to put your ego in
check it's really hard to put your ego
in check and actually listen to what the
critique points are it's easy it's hard
for anyone to do that you know and so
when it happens you have to go okay
that's my ego and you need to put it
aside yeah so consider this situation if
the guy would have just said don't say I
showed it to my wife and she said this
don't say if he would have said well I
was thinking about this which is what
the wife said you know in there whatever
I was figure out this whether it would
add it got delivered way better way
easier the same thing with your your
situation if someone's saying I don't
know let's say for example it's a
fireman it's a farm and you know the
boss is saying hey we should do this and
do that and then this guy just horribly
says so we'll Jocko said the bosses like
who the hell is John I don't remember
hiring Joe who's this guy and what's he
talking about
cool but Jaco has no say in this
department it's me it's you it's the
team you know the team that we've worked
with kind of thing that's kind of the
feeling so yeah men don't say jock yeah
I don't need to credit not all